on va simplement créer un nom de domaine
le plus crédible possible donc faut que
ce soit HTTPS tu vas cliquer sur le lien
tu vas pouvoir cliquer sur Autoriser
parce que bien sûr tu fais pas attention
à ce que tu fais tu vois là je suis en
train de récupérer des photos de toi
je passe vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de
temps sur mon téléphone et parfois je me
fais des petits coups de Philippe quand
je suis sur les réseaux ou sur des
applis je me demande si il est possible
pour une personne de contrôler mon
téléphone à distance par exemple
d'allier ma caméra à mon insu ou de mes
gévocaliser sans que je le sache en fait
j'aimerais savoir s'il est possible de
traquer de manière illégale via mon tél
pour Bridger demandé à cœur de pirater
mon smartphone on peut prendre le
contrôle de ton téléphone à distance
ouais ok l'objectif pour moi ça va être
d'installer sur ton téléphone un virus
ce virus il va me donner un contrôle de
ton téléphone pour ça on va utiliser une
application que les gens utilisent
beaucoup en ce moment on va injecter le
virus dans l'application comme ça au
moment où toi tu vas installer via un
lien que je vais t'envoyer et bien
normalement je devrais prendre le
contrôle de l'appareil on a choisi de ne
pas divulguer l'appli dont ces servi
Thomas pour le hacking mais il faut
savoir qu'on peut injecter un virus dans
à peu près n'importe quelle application
je vais simplement t'envoyer un petit un
petit message sur WhatsApp on va dire
hello Mina
et je te mets un petit lien de
téléchargement
c'est là que on rentre en compte
l'ingénierie sociale en hacking c'est à
dire qu'il faut trouver de bonnes
raisons pour faire installer
l'application donc là tu peux cliquer
sur le lien pour télécharger
l'application
que on a l'application qui est
complètement et sur mon ordi du coup je
vais lancer un monitoring en gros je
vais écouter les connexions et c'est ton
téléphone qui va se connecter à mon
programme au moment où on va ouvrir
l'application c'est parti et là on voit
que ça se lance et là je viens de
récupérer l'accès au téléphone donc là
ça contrôle sur mon téléphone donc là
j'ai en tout cas suffisamment de
contrôle pour commencer à faire des
trucs intéressants je peux par exemple
récupérer la liste des sms je peux
récupérer la liste des contacts je peux
te géolocaliser en boucle pour savoir
exactement où tu es je peux aussi te
mettre sur écoute ça c'est intéressant
pour écouter toutes les conversations
d'une pièce là on est vraiment sur un
outil ciblé espionnage en fait on vient
de récupérer la liste de tous les SMS
qui sont sur l'appareil on a le numéro
on a le message on a toutes les toutes
les infos dont on a besoin d'après moi
le plus critique avec ça c'est qu'on a
surtout accès au micro donc
potentiellement on peut te mettre sur
écoute on essaie et là à partir de
maintenant tout ce qu'on dit le
téléphone il est en train de
l'enregistrer tu peux parler tu vas voir
on va réécouter après
ce genre de virus à trouver c'est
terriblement facile là toutes les démos
que je fais c'est avec des outils alors
une partie des outils que j'ai créé moi
une partie des outils qui sont open
source qui sont libres d'accès sur
Internet
et sur mon téléphone je vois rien
coucher de teint l'application alors là
si tu éteins l'application en fait tant
qu'elle est en veille et qu'elle tombe
dans le téléphone moi je garderai un
accès si tu coupes l'application moi je
parle accès
j'ai aucun risque et alors aucun risque
on peut pas dire ça parce que
régulièrement on trouve quand même des
pays laudes des virus dans certaines
applications de l'Apple Store mais c'est
tout l'intérêt de ce système là en fait
est-ce que tu peux déclencher ma caméra
à distance je vais devoir te pousser à
cliquer sur l'autorisation de la caméra
donc pour ça on va devoir quand même
essayer de jouer un petit peu sur les
émotions sur la peur les pirates ils
aiment bien faire ça on va simplement
créer un nom de domaine le plus crédible
possible donc faut que ce soit HTTPS ici
tu vois on a le lien que je vais
t'envoyer concrètement on a quoi tu vois
on a bien acheté TPS on a bien
instagram.com et évidemment l'arnaque
elle est juste derrière mais celui qui
fait pas attention il a vraiment
l'impression que c'est un lien Instagram
le but c'est de te faire peur donc
écrire wow c'est pas toi sur cette vidéo
on a tous déjà reçu ça sur messenger ou
sur des trucs comme ça donc là tu vois
tu vas cliquer sur le lien
voilà tu te vois un petit peu on voit un
truc en flou c'est pas trop ce que c'est
tu vas pouvoir cliquer sur Autoriser
parce que bien sûr tu fais pas attention
à ce que tu fais et tu vois là je suis
en train de récupérer des photos de toi
alors ça c'est très pratique quand on
veut essayer de trouver qui se cache
derrière un réseau social ou derrière un
numéro de téléphone je crois que j'ai
déjà cliqué sur autorisé au moins une ou
deux fois mais bien sûr mais on le fait
tous je m'amuse pas à pirater les gens
je m'amuse pas à pirater des entreprises
par contre j'aime comprendre comment ça
fonctionne j'aime voilà qu'on prend un
petit peu les méthodes qui permettent
d'entrer dans des systèmes mais le but
c'est aussi de comprendre un petit peu
comment on peut se protéger de tout ça
Thomas m'a donné quelques conseils pour
éviter de se faire pirater d'abord il
faut toujours faire ses mises à jour les
pirates ont plus facilement accès à des
failles de sécurité si le téléphone
n'est pas à jour toujours téléchargez
les applis via les stores officiels ça
peut paraître évident mais ne pas
hésiter à choisir des mots de passe
compliqués si vos données fuites le
hacker mettra beaucoup plus de temps à
décrypter votre mot de passe il est
difficile évidemment ne pas faire comme
moi ne pas cliquer sur les liens envoyés
par des inconnus ou des personnes non
dans les pas sûr de l'identité les plus
gros piratages de l'histoire c'est à
cause du comportement des humains
rarement à cause du comportement des
ordinateurs